enfin oui enfin nous voici tous
rassembler mes chers amis rassemblés
pour gagner les régionales bien sûr mais
rassembler pour gagner en 2010 est
également et surtout rassembler pour
reconstruire une france qui n'est plus
que l'ombre d'elle-même car telle est
notre véritable défi aujourd'hui les
enjeux sont immenses
nous le savons tous ils sont immenses
car les attentes des français sont
immenses il faut redonner la confiance
et de l'espoir aux français car leur
colère gronde chaque jour un peu plus
même si certains ne veulent rien
entendre
il nous faut ramener d'urgence les
brebis égarées du front national vers la
république car nous avons le devoir de
leur ouvrir les yeux et il me faut et il
ne faut pas compter sur la peau sur la
gauche pour cela car le fn ps est une
triste réalité politique et nous le
savons tous
n'ayons pas peur de dire aux français
que marine le pen leur ment et les
trahira jamais marine le pen ne leur
trouvera un emploi
le front national n'est pas un parti de
gouvernement
il ne le fera jamais il n'est qu'un
parti d'agitation
il est incapable de diriger une commune
incapable de diriger une région
incapable de diriger un pays
d'ailleurs rappelé vous rappelez vous le
soir du premier tour de 2002 jean marie
le pen panique angoisse vertige mais
comment vais-je faire pour au président
et avec qui avec quel programme
c'était panique à bord au fonds national
alors ne l'oublié jamais mes chers amis
le fond nationalement ils agitent les
peurs joue avec les passions et fait le
grand écart entre l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite mais jamais non jamais
ils n'apportent des solutions pour la
france et les français
alors nous nous les républiques à nous
mèneront le combat notre combat contre
notre ennemi qui est le front national
est notre adversaire qui est le parti
socialiste notre combat contre le
populisme de madame le pen et contre la
gauche communautariste de monsieur
hollande et monsieur valls car nous nous
avons choisi la voie de la république
la seule qui soit durable et fidèle à
l'identité de la france
alors soyons fiers fiers d'être les
républicains je refuse de croire que
l'âme de la france soit morte
je refuse de croire que la place de la
france parmi les grandes nations de ce
monde puisse être perdus à jamais je
refuse de croire que la république soit
devenu le guichet automatique de
l'assistanat et le laboratoire du
multiculturalisme mielleux de la gauche
je le refuse
alors soyons unis unie et indivisible
car nous sommes des citoyens
soyons unis et indivisible car nous
avons les mêmes droits et les mêmes
devoirs
c'est de voir ses devoirs qu'ils sont
six absents du quinquennat de françois
hollande les devoirs qui font si peur à
madame taubira et pourtant chers amis je
vous le dis la république est une
exigence de tous les jours une société
sans devoir n'existe pas alors pour la
reconstruire il va falloir être ferme
pour la reconstruire il ne faut pas
avoir la main qui tremble pour la
reconstruire il va falloir du courage
mais le courage et républicains nous ne
manquons pas le courage
le courage le courage et dans notre adn
il est dans notre histoire car ne
l'oublions jamais nous sommes les
héritiers de la france résistante
nous sommes les héritiers de ceux qui
ont eu le courage de dire non non à la
négation de notre histoire
non à la disparition de notre identité
non à la tyrannie des minorités et non
au diktat de la pensée unique
quand on est républicain on lutte contre
le communautarisme on lutte contre
l'assistanat sans contrepartie et on se
bat pour l'école publique et le mérite
quand on est républicain on lutte contre
le bolloc'h livre libertaire de gauche
qui chaque jour des construit notre
société quand on est républicain
on n'a pas peur de dire qu'il faut
mettre fin à schengen et qu'il faut
intervenir militairement en syrie avec
une coalition internationale contre la
bête immonde kedech
plus que jamais mes chers amis nous
avons le devoir de dire la vérité la
vérité vis-à-vis de nos électeurs
bien sûr la vérité vis-à-vis des
français et la vérité vis-à-vis de la
france
la vérité la vérité c'est de dire que la
france ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde
la vérité c'est de dire que la
république est rongée par le
communautarisme
non madame vallaud belkacem le mérite le
travail l'effort ne sont pas des gros
mots non madame taubira la politique
pénale n'est pas au service des
délinquants mais au service des victimes
la vérité
la vérité c'est de dire à monsieur valls
qu'on ne reçoit pas la table de la
république
les leaders communautariste la vérité
c'est de dire à monsieur hollande que
quand on fait la guerre ont neuf quand
on fait la guerre on l'a fait de façon
totale car notre ennemi nous l'a fait de
manière totale
notre ennemi dèche alors la liste est
longue mais amy hélas elle est à l'image
de la lâcheté et de l'impuissance des
socialistes à gouverner la france
alors oui les chemins seront long et
sinueux mais l'heure est proche
elle est toute proche mais ses amis et
nous serons là présents rassemblés pour
reconstruire ensemble la france
notre volonté est grande je le sais mais
n'oubliez pas que notre responsabilité
il est encore plus alors ensemble
construisons la france de demain et
ensemble construisons une république
forte et une france fière d'elle-même
merci